good evening bienvenidos and thank you
to everyone here today endeavoring
towards a better
more just future alexandria
ocasio-cortez made a
super quick appearance during night two
of the democratic national convention
tuesday and
viewers were left kind of confused by it
i hereby second the nomination of
senator bernard sanders of vermont
for president of the united states of
america
yeah she wrapped up her speech
nominating bernie
sanders for president
huh but the congresswoman who had
endorsed sanders last october before it
became clear that biden would become the
democratic nominee hit up twitter
shortly
after her speech to explain the whole
thing quote
if you were confused no worries
convention rules require
roll call and nominations for every
candidate that passes the delegate
threshold
i extend my deepest congratulations to
joe biden
let's go win in november makes sense
right
well it didn't stop there following
aoc's speech
twitter lit up with all sorts of
commentary
and the 30 year old politician wasted no
time responding to critics for their
malicious
and misleading headlines she tweeted
quote
this is completely unacceptable
disappointing and
appalling damn you tell him girl
but ocasio-cortez's quickie speech
wasn't the only thing that had people
talking about the dnc
courage unity and patriotism are as
important today
as they were in 1960. yeah that tall
drink of water is jfk's 27 year old
grandson
jack schlossberg standing next to his
mom
caroline kennedy in this election our
future is on the ballot
the two threw their support behind joe
biden on tuesday
and jack's appearance had people thirsty
for him
and democracy it's up to us let's get it
done
let's select joe biden the next
president of the united states
let me just save you some time and give
you the scoop on jack
he's the only grandson of jfk and he's
expressed an
interest in politics he graduated from
yale in 2015 and
entered harvard law school in the fall
of 2017.
he started at harvard business school in
2018
and that same year he made his acting
debut in the season eight finale of blue
bloods
guy looking for you out back manuel
something you know him
yeah he said he doesn't want to come in
that's that's cool thanks jack
hot right yeah well the folks at home
thought so too
and twitter blew up after his dnc moment
with
thoughts like jack schlossberg could get
elected president in the future
and my personal fave my takeaway from
knight 2
so far is that i'm very attracted to
jack schlossberg
so i'm not worried about it
john legend also backed joe biden and
brought the house down with his soulful
performance of never break
we will never break
[Applause]
build our foundation strong enough to
stay
but of course the biggest news of the
night joe biden
officially accepted the democratic
nomination for president
thank you all it means the world to me
and my family
after all 57 states and territories
participated in the roll call across
america
the former vice president collected 2687
delegates to formally accept the
nomination
his wife jill was right by his side for
the big moment
and shortly after he took to twitter
writing
it is the honor of my life to accept the
democratic party's nomination for
president of the united states of
america
well thank you very very much from the
bottom of my heart